our guest Paul Krugman is a new york
times columnist also the winner of the
Nobel Prize in Economics thank you for
being here this morning thanks for
having me on his book and this
depression now is out in paperback a lot
of people have criticized you in the
last couple of weeks including joe
scarborough when you weren't Morning Joe
for not worrying enough about the debt
is that fair I certainly worry about it
a lot less than has been the
conventional view in Washington but I'm
right I mean it's a it you know we have
a there are some long-term issues about
how we're going to pay for the things we
want from the federal government so
there no one sensible denies that if we
think about where we're going to be in
the year twenty twenty-five we're going
to have to make some choices but is the
debt a current problem right now with
the US government able to borrow more
cheaply than ever before with reasonable
forecast showing the debt situation
fairly stable for the next ten years or
so it's just this is an obsession that
is getting in the way of dealing with
what is the clear and present problem
which is mass unemployment here's the
headline in a political story that mr.
Scarborough wrote Paul Krugman versus
the world are you alone on this no
that's really and that's that's an
amazing thing I think there's this kind
of closed loop of beltway conventional
wisdom where people think nobody nobody
has those views that krugman has nobody
all accepted well yon hat seus chief
economist of Goldman Sachs Larry Summers
pretty much former Treasury Secretary
Martin wolf the chief economics editor
of the Financial Times you know a lot of
alan blinder it's my colleague at
Princeton but also former deputy
chairman of the Federal Reserve all of
those people have said more or less the
same thing i have not maybe as
colorfully but there's this amazing sort
of you know we only talked to people who
confirm our prejudices and it's all
wrong and it's very destructive Erskine
Bowles was interviewed in Forbes this
week and it's he says national debt
threatens us innovation he said when I
think about the consequences of debt I
think about things slowing down and
grinding to a halt debt is a drag on
everything no I mean at the moment the
drag on everything is that we have
almost four million people who've been
out of work for more than a year which
is unprecedented since the Great
Depression that we have a depressed
economy if there aren't sales if
companies can't see grow
why are they going to innovate the most
important thing is to get this economy
moving which for the time being means
more not less government spending is
there a difference between a national
economy dealing with debt and a business
dealing with debt yes harrell elder made
office yeah parallel with a business
actually in some ways if we if we did it
like a business we'd be behaving very
differently from the way we are right
now you know of business if if you have
record low borrowing costs you would
actually do some more investment and
what we've actually done in this last
few years we've actually slashed public
investment we've been canceling
infrastructure projects we've been
putting you know the pothole repairs on
hold but the other thing and it's also
that people make the analogy by the
household with the family and the big
difference is if a family cuts it
spending well it cuts it spending and it
can maybe it has the same income but in
the economy as a whole you know my
spending is your income your spending is
my income if we all cut at the same time
our incomes go down we get a depression
and it's the job of the government to
understand that feedback and not to join
in the scramble to cut spending at a
time when the economy is weak Paul
Krugman's book is end this depression
now it's out in paperback if you'd like
to join the conversation here are the
numbers to call democrats 2025 853 880
Republicans 2025 853 881 and
independents 2025 853 882 on Twitter
boringfileclerk writes in and asks in
your opinion were in another depression
not a recession yeah I like to there's
two things one is a recession is when
you are going down a depression is when
you are down so you know the US economy
was growing from nineteen thirty three
to nineteen thirty-seven but we were
still in the depths of the Great
Depression and we're now in something
that of course it's not the Great
Depression it's the lesser depression if
you like that but still very high
unemployment and also crucially a
situation in which they are the normal
the aspirin you take for a minor
headache the you know cuts in the
interest rate at the Federal Reserve is
not available because interest rates are
already 0 so you do need other policies
so we're in depression conditions mild
depression conditions but depression and
we are suffering from depression
economics so a depression is the right
word for what we're experiencing let's
take a listen to Congressman Paul Ryan
he spoke at the National Review
Institute summit in Washington
Lee about the dangers of debt we spent a
trillion dollars more than we take in
each year we can't keep that up if we
stay on this path we will run the risk
of a debt crisis what is that that's a
moment where our finances collapse our
economy stalls we will have to convince
the country to change course Congressman
Paul Ryan former vice presidential
candidate are we in danger of collapse a
stall a crisis no I mean it's there's a
whole bunch of reasons why that's not
true first of all that trillion-dollar
almost the Iowa is here dr. evil saying
one trillion dollars now if trillion
dollar deficit is overwhelmingly the
result of a depressed economy and when
the economy's depressed as good to run a
deficit you don't want the government to
try and balance its budget right now but
also the United States is a country that
has its own currency can't run out of
cash because we print the money if you
even try to think what would happen
supposed investors get down on the
United States even so what that would do
is weaken the dollar not send interest
rates soaring and that would be good
that would help our exports the story
Ryan is trying to tell just doesn't
actually make sense it there's no there
are no historical counterparts to the
story he claims we're at risk of and of
course the Ryan himself you know he
desperately desperately concerned about
the deficit but won't accept one penny
an additional revenue to deal with it
all he really wants is to is to cut
spending if it comes to making any
sacrifice on what he cares about which
is taxes he's not willing to make that
sacrifice why is there a national
interest in focus right now on the debt
if you do a Google search of debt and
deficit there are a lot of stories from
the past year as we've looked at raising
the debt ceiling and dealing with debt
issues well one thing is that you know
the number is bigger there's one
trillion dollars and so that cats gets
people's attention but also I think you
know we like to have economic analysis
we like to think things through and
think that that matters but politicians
often go with gut feelings and the gut
sense is that well you know we're
borrowing a lot that must be a bad thing
there's a lot of lot of people who are
trying to use the deficit as an excuse
to you know kill Social Security and
Medicare basically so
all this complex of things comes
together and it's it's a completely
misplaced focused but it's you know this
always happens when you have a depressed
economy same thing that led FDR to cut
spending in 1937 when he really
shouldn't have done that let's get to
the phones and hear from steve in
phoenix on our democrats line hi Steve I
good morning how are you morning my
questions for mr. Krugman has a lot to
do with the last guide mr. Gutierrez it
was on the phone I work at a trucking
company in Phoenix Arizona and we
constantly see a downward pressure on
wages especially through the
encouragement of illegal aliens coming
into our country and my question for mr.
Krugman is uh with the constant
pressures for I mean even to the point
of illegal pressures for wages how do
you raise your wages well okay I mean I
that's is that's a whole other issue I
think would take us way away from most
of them we won't talk about but um the
effects of immigration illegal
immigration on the economy are a little
complicated it I there's even dispute
among economists about how much it
depresses the wages of low-skilled
workers the United States why I'm in the
camp that says it does it's it's part of
the growing it's it's part of the
problem of inequality but I don't think
it's actually central to what we're
going what's going on right now I mean
what we need right now is we just need
to have some growth in the overall
economy we need to have more demand more
sales the at the margin those jobs are
not going to be filled by illegal
immigrants those going to be jobs for
Americans and and and that's where we
need to go and yes let's let's work on
immigration policy but that's a whole
other different can of worms Frank and
largo florida independent caller go
ahead yes mr. krugman this is frank
you're a proponent of kenzie and
economics and i found out recently that
word John Maynard Keynes was not only
are you Genesis but he was the treasurer
for the eugenics Society of England and
I was wondering if you read his paper
some social or some economic conquest
consequences of a declining population
and are you a you Jenna sister stock
come on this is stupid and as I
shouldn't say that to a code but stupid
he
some foolish stuff when he was 18 years
old and it was still basically Victorian
Britain and a lot of people held
disagreeable views from our point of
view right right now and that's a shame
but that has nothing at all to do with
his economic analysis right there lots
of lots of bad people have had good
economic ideas and unfortunate lots of
good people have had bad economic ideas
and that's what we're talking about if
you're gonna you know I don't think I
wrote anything when I was 18 years old
that would look terrible but but lots of
people probably did what about his
economic philosophy appeals to you you
read about it a lot in your columns well
I don't think it's a philosophy that
appeals to me it's a model of how the
world works that actually works right
meaning if you came into this you know
four years ago with a Keynesian point of
view you said things that were regarded
as outrageous in this town you said
government borrowing won't send interest
rates skyrocketing the Fed printing
money won't cause inflation and by the
way austerity policies will tank the
economies that adopt them and all of
that has come true so you know you have
you have a theory that works that I
don't care about the philosophy and I
don't care what John Maynard Keynes may
have thought when he was a when he was a
teenager let's go to the phones and hear
from Marion in West Bloomfield Michigan
Republican caller hi Miriam yes good
morning when I like to uh ask God mr.
Krugman are how many years has he been
yeah and economic of you know so
so-called expert and what does he think
about the Reagan administration having
the economy doing so well because he
lowered the taxes and W are Bush WG boot
is that the right one uh well w bush the
second board president had a very well
economy we were doing well we didn't
have such high unemployment what does he
think about those two okay so I've been
in this business longer than I care to
imagine actually i was i was in the
reagan administration sort of not
political level but i was a the senior
international economist with the staff
of the Council of Economic Advisers in
1982 1983 my domestic counterpart was a
guy by the name of Larry Summers anyway
um no
Reagan the Reagan had a good economic
recovery which was because the Federal
Reserve which had raised interest rates
sky high then cut them again and to the
extent that his policies did contribute
it was actually because he provided a
pretty big Keynesian stimulus with tax
cuts and military spending the bush
economy was not a good economy come on
me and what about the Clinton economy
you know Bill Clinton raise tax rates on
the rich and thought people said oats
now although all of you know Wall Street
Journal Forbes all said we're going to
have a terrible recession what we had
was actually the best economy we've had
since the 1960s what's been the impact
of Keynesian economics on the Obama
administration the choice is made
internally well they certainly went
Keynesian in the initial stimulus bill
but well short it was a much smaller
plan than a straight Keynesian analysis
would have have said and then they they
actually got cold feet late in 2009 a
lot of us were saying you need to do
more and they they turn to conventional
and of course since the midterm
elections they haven't had the ability
to pass much of anything except actually
the payroll tax cut which was a
Keynesian policy and it looks like it
did quite a lot to boost the economy but
unfortunately just went away how long
will have to elapse before we know what
succeeded or failed during this time
period well I mean people are still
arguing about the 1930s right I think
there's some or the old you know how
evaluating the French Revolution too
soon to tell but but I think I think we
already have a tremendous amount of
evidence I mean we've been running
unfortunately very cruel unethical human
experiments all across the advanced
world we look at what has happened in
Europe we look at the effects of
austerity policies in Britain in Ireland
and Greece and Spain so we know that
those don't work we have a lot of
information about the effects of
monetary policy Europe and the United
States we have a pretty good idea that
that it's hard to make it work at these
levels but we also know that fears of
inflation were grossly exaggerated so
actually all the evidence we need to
make a sensible set of policies is out
there right now since our last caller
asked about your credentials let's talk
a little bit about what Paul Krugman has
done he's a columnist for The New York
Times means a professor of economics and
international affairs at Princeton
University he's also taught at Yale MIT
and Stanford and he's the author or
editor of
20 books and more than 200 papers in
professional journals he's the Nobel
Prize winner in economics and his most
recent book now out in paperback is end
this depression now Janet's up next in
Mount Prospect Illinois Democrats line
hi Janet hi good morning is where to
stick with You dr. Krugman and I was
wondering the financial crisis brought
about by the housing collapse had we
done more stimulus would it be possible
if we've gotten back to full employment
quicker that interest rates may have
risen and therefore depressed a recovery
in the housing market well okay interest
rates if we were doing better interest
rates would be somewhat higher that's
the interest rates are low basically
because people don't see anything to
spend on they don't want to borrow
businesses don't want to borrow because
they they don't see a demand out there
so sure but that would have been I think
way more than offset and particular on
the housing market the biggest thing
holding back the housing market actually
right now is the weak job market
household formation is way down which is
basically saying a lot of kids who want
to I'm old enough now 30 year old
sometimes looks like a kid to me but a
lot of young people are still living
with their parents unable to start a
family unable to move out on their own
because they don't have jobs and if we
had a stronger economy they would that
would translate into demand for housing
and would be a stronger economy across
the board one of the ways we encourage
our viewers listeners to reach out is
through social media we talk about
Facebook and Twitter there's also tout
which is a way to send a short video
clip let's take a listen to one of the
talents that came in a question for mr.
Krugman a question for Paul Krugman Paul
I was hoping that you could baby khao
pun intended the pros and cons of the
plus side versus trickle-down economics
course thank you I'm sorry to supply
side versus trickle-down economics I
thought they were mostly the same thing
mean the there is this notion that if
you cut taxes on rich people that
somehow that benefits everybody and you
know if we had ninety percent tax rates
on the topping comes I might even have a
little sympathy for that point of view
but of course we don't in fact a lot of
people top income
paying tax rates of like thirteen or
fourteen percent like a guy who just
lost the race for president the other
day and there's this case with just no
evidence it's one of those things that
despite being refuted by one study after
another despite the fact that we did
very well in the 90s when tax rates were
raised and did pretty badly of the years
following although tax rates for the
rich were cut people still believe it
and of course that that has a lot to do
with who actually pays the bills for a
lot of politicians here's a question on
Twitter please comment on the Bush
administration's lack of concern for the
debt like vice president Cheney's
assertions to that effect that's right
when when Bush was and this is a the
extent that you have any concerns about
the debt you should be really really
angry at what happened during the bush
years because we did have a reasonably
strong not great but reasonably strong
economy in the middle years of the last
decade and that's a time when you should
be paying down debt that the whole point
is you're supposed to yeah we were
paying down debt at the end of the 90s
Bush squandered that on tax cuts and
unfunded Wars and then when the economy
strengthened again in the mid-2000s
again the complete disregard they didn't
care they didn't have any interest in
paying down the debt and if they had
done what they were supposed to do we
would have come into this crisis with
quite a lot less debt and maybe the
deficit hawks would you a little bit
quieter than they are right now let's
hear from Chris Houston Texas
independent hi Chris hi how are you guys
thank mr. Krugman have two quick
questions for you than I hanging Melissa
first of all I'm not a big fan of Kings
i'm a fan of marie rockball and what's
kind of subscribe to the austrian school
but uh my first question Bernanke has
has lately come on record saying you
know talking about the quantitative
easing say basically printing money out
of thin air and just on from a
common-sense perspective he claims that
he hasn't seen any signs of inflation
yet and once he does so kind of pull
back on the QE my question is I mean
just economics 101 the more money to
print the more inflation results and I'm
just worried the dollar
been a lot of trouble and second of all
just the top tax rate in Russia just
went up to 39 point very excuse me in
the u.s. just went up to thirty nine
point six percent they've got a flat tax
in Russia of 13 now without having an
hour to get into this I'm just thinking
I know there are different situations
but case the u.s. do better than Russia
on taxes Wow the inflation thing I think
this is it's very important to
understand that this has been tested
mean if people have been saying all that
fed money printing is going to cause
lots of inflation have been saying that
for five years now and it keeps not
happening and don't tell me that the
numbers are skewed they're not we have
lots of evidence that they that by any
measure inflation estate low so at what
point do you say gee I guess the people
are telling me this have got the wrong
model of how the world works they just
they're just not right and if you're not
willing to say that then you know then I
can't deal with it we're talking about
matters of faith that are not not
susceptible to evidence so that the
whole inflation worry is something that
is is now it's now turning into
something that's irrational if that's
what you're still worried about I don't
think that the measure of a country's
success is is how low the top tax rate
is right I mean would you rather live in
Russia would you drive to live in Sweden
I think I think I take Sweden and so I
mean the fact the matter is that we you
know we can argue if you if you would
like to have lower tax rates at the top
then you have to tell me what social
programs you know what are the big cuts
in Social Security and Medicare that you
want to make because that's where by and
large the taxpayer dollar goes but
there's no evidence at all in history
our own history looking across the world
that tax rates at the levels we
currently have are a big problem for the
economy comment on Twitter with a
question there has to be some negatives
when the government borrows so much
money to cover its increasing spending
what are these negatives right now
they're very very small in fact is not
entirely clear that there are any
negatives right now there's a pretty
reasonable case that even if the only
thing you care about is the government
budget that borrowing more is a good
thing because or blood put that like
spending less if we try to
cut our deficit by spending less will
depress the economy which will depress
revenues and will also hurt future
growth if you keep people unemployed for
long periods of time they may never be
enter the workforce if there are no job
for college graduates they will never
get started on their careers and that
means that you're hurting the future
taxpayers of America as well so right
now with us borrowing costs so low the
odds are that there's minimal and maybe
negative costs two extra government
borrowing Paul Krugman author of the
book and this depression now which just
came out in paperback he's a columnist
for The New York Times and teaches at
Princeton Brian's our next caller in
vancouver washington on the republicans
line welcome Brian hi uh I'm a pretty
simple guy so I just I'm trying to
understand this but uh you know we're
borrowing trillions and uh you know when
when does it all end it seems to me that
you can't just continuously keep
borrowing this money and expect it not
to have a bad consequence I mean if we
make the apart gross national income is
10 trillion a year then shouldn't we try
and spend less than that I mean we just
wiped out the entire tax increase all
the money we would have gained from that
bailing out hurricane sandy how can we
afford this I mean isn't it time we just
look at our entire situation and say you
know we can't afford this no more
vacations this year this is you know we
got it we got a deal with this but look
at how it actually plays out if you were
worried that we are spending too much we
need to work more then how is it that it
makes sense to have a policy that
actually leads to us working less
because that's what slashing government
spending and the depressed economy does
the government cuts it spending the
economy is depressed and the private
sector is not spending enough then what
you're doing is you're raising
unemployment and what kind of bizarre
view of the world does it is is the way
to deal with the debt problem to to have
lots of people quit their jobs that's
the point now I'm altering deficit hawk
once the economy is stronger once we're
somewhere close to full employment but
right now you do need actually as you
said think of the whole picture and you
think of the whole picture the picture
is that our income is very closely
related
our spending again my spending is your
income your spending is my income if all
we try and do is cut spending what we do
is reduce our incomes would make the
economy more deeply depressed that's not
helping anybody our guest holds a PhD
from MIT he went to Yale University for
his undergraduate degrees and as we
mentioned earlier he's written more than
200 papers and professional journals and
also written or edited 20 books here's a
question for you from oversight of GOP
one of her followers on Twitter mr.
Krugman should there be sequestration
cuts if not how would you replace them
well in general spending cuts right now
is a bad thing we don't want we don't
want to you know that we're talking
about a pretty significant hit 222
growth if the sequestration goes through
do you think it will um I don't think so
I mean it's a political judgment so you
know I have no special expertise here
but I don't think so in the end the
sequestration is going to hit you know
military spending especially hard and
the funny thing about Republicans is
they're absolutely opposed to Keynesian
economics the idea that government
spending can create jobs unless its
military is Barney Frank calls it
weaponized keynesianism so since they
are in fact weaponized Keynesian I think
in the end they'll back down on this and
they should let's hope this doesn't
happen what would you see it we replaced
with I mean well I remembered nothing
we're getting into politics here and
just on bargaining chips are but just
well I think I think just what you know
say hey we should not be cutting
spending while the unemployment rate is
this high that's the destroyer back you
know and let's talk about in the year
twenty twenty how we're going to help
pay our bills in the year twenty
twenty-five but not cutting spending
while the economy is still in a
depression speaking of politics your
recent column makers takers and fakirs
in the new york times you say
republicans have a problem for yours
they could shout down any attempt to
point out the extent to which their
policies favor the elite over the poor
and middle class all they had to do was
yell class warfare and Democrats
scurried away in the twenty twelve
election however that didn't work the
picture of the GOP is the party of
sneering plutocrats stuck even as
Democrats became more openly populists
than they had been in decades yeah it's
this was a much closer I mean that this
was unabashed on the part of Obama on
the part of many Democrats they are
unabashed about saying
look we are not going to support
policies that continue to transfer
income upwards from the middle-class and
low-income Americans to to the top 1%
and it seems to have been a political
winner certainly they weren't punished
so the they old fear that any hint that
you were going to even talk about
inequality and the way in which
government policies has been reinforcing
inequality was poison that's been
dispelled and Republicans you look at
the language Republicans are using their
now acknowledging that they have at
least an image problem although they're
not willing to actually change their
policies Indianapolis Indiana
independent color of Jim hi Jim hello uh
mr. Krugman I agree with you that uh now
is the time for the government to be
spending more and but I'm concerned
about uh possibly other ways that we can
be raised in revenue or changing how we
create money as far as raising revenue
what do you think of a small Tobin tax
on the on the stock market and as far as
creation of money have you looked at the
IMF paper that came out of the summer
that was a called the Chicago plan
revisited no I'm the second part no I'm
sorry I missed that I normally catch
everything that they published by missed
that one uh Tobin tax by waiting for
people who don't know Tobin taxes
attacks on financial transactions was
originally proposed as a tax on foreign
exchange trading now people say maybe
the stock market maybe all financial
transactions and I'm for it i think it's
it's a we probably have too much
churning in our financial markets we
have financial markets are two hair
trigger and you besides you can raise
some additional revenues so I'm forth
although I don't think it's a terribly
important policy but I'm for it the
Europeans are putting in a mild one will
raise a little bit of revenues so sure
by all means let's let's let's let's add
that to the Arsenal policies we use to
try and calm down this excessively
financialized volatile economy we've
developed Brian in Baltimore Democrats
line go ahead caller I all big fan of
yours I like you have been mystified
four years of how a possible problem but
Pacific may or may not happen 15 or 20
years out is managed to dominate the
conversation of perks paying jobs now
here's my question for you it's been
sort of my suspicion that the that the
GOP has been so successful in getting a
lot of you
drink the kool-aid on this is because if
the real goal has been to reduce the
size of government to start the
government spending and they come out
and say that so by talking about that
and opposite it sort of gets to their
real goal to the back door and what I
was wondering is if you had some inning
up to what the real goal is at the GOP
here because it Bobby deficit was
demonstrated by the Ryan plan so what'd
he find a real answer well that's not
even that that's not even particularly
hidden the mean for since since the
Reagan years Republicans have talked
about the strategy of starve the Beast
cut taxes then use the deficits that
result as a way to to push for cuts in
government programs so I mean that's
that's explicit in a way what now
they're saying claiming to be deeply
deeply concerned about the deficit but
the deficits were actually part of the
plan this is this is this is exactly
what they were you know this financial
crisis if you like was what they were
working towards or this perception of a
fiscal crisis is what they were working
towards and if you look at the actual
plans you look at Paul Ryan's plans they
are actually deficit increasing plans
right he says that he's got big cuts in
taxes and then offset by things to be
specified there are big cuts and social
programs but they're not actually enough
to offset the tax cuts and all the rest
of the alleged improvement on the
deficit comes from magic asterisk from
from you know additional revenue but not
they won't tell you what and additional
spending cuts but they won't tell you
what so it's very clear that the whole
purpose is to use the anxiety over the
deficit to slash Medicare to slash those
security to up to savage Medicaid and
that the deficit is just an excuse for
doing that dr. crookman doesn't matter
who holds the US debt here's the
Washington Post giving us a graphic of
China's holdings of US debt you can see
China's holdings of US Treasury bonds
and then China's holdings as a
percentage of US public debt it matters
almost not at all it's uh you know II
suppose that we had domestic investors
and I was supposed that domestic
billionaire's were holding all of the
depth do we think that they would refuse
to sell those bonds out of patriotism
you know come on it and on the other
hand we think that the Chinese are going
to be
especially irrational again not in the
only thing I would say is actually the
extent that the Chinese own a lot of our
debt that man sort of strengthen our
position if they all line if if you know
somebody at ten thousand dollars you
have a problem if you own 10 million
dollars he has a problem and I think
that the fact that the Chinese own so
much u.s. debt marginally weakens their
bargaining position versus the United
States we just got a glimpse of the
National Debt Clock we can show that
again on the screen 16 trillion dollars
and Counting is there a number that
frightens you uh it would have to be a
lot bigger I look at Japan Japan has
their their gross debt relative to GDP
is more than twice hours and they are
still able to borrow very cheaply and
they just announced a new set of
stimulus programs and and you might say
well surely that will cause the markets
to panic and in fact the markets are
delighted Japanese stock market's been
surging so it does countries that borrow
in their own currency that have stable
governments which I think we do still
have enormous amount of Running Room so
not you know don't not nothing that I
see happening in the next decade makes
me worry at all about that position Paul
Krugman has a recent column in The New
York Times called Japan steps out where
he talks about the economy of that
country that's January thirteenth you
can find that on the New York Times
website New York nytimes com Larry Tulsa
Oklahoma Democrat hi professor Krugman I
want to thank you for your erudition and
for your willingness to fight for what
you believe in on a daily basis through
your column it's really been
inspirational my question to you is how
would you fashion stimulus program with
specifics with you put in it for uh
president obama to unveil in the state
of the union message wow I mean there's
question of what's ideal in the question
of what is politically possible and then
there's sort of in between what is
politically plausible although unlikely
to happen politically possible is almost
nothing it's not going to get any real
stimulus bill passed those Republicans
and in the house ideal I would like to
see a whole bunch of things I think we
should be doing a lot more investment in
in medium term public
structure projects energy transportation
fixing our water systems is a big big
unmet need and so on in the enemy range
which one I actually call for in end
this depression now we could get a lot
of pretty quick boost to the economy
simply by providing aid to state and
local governments to reverse the
spending cuts that they've made rehire
those hundreds of thousands of layoffs
school teachers resume all of those you
know very mundane public investment
projects like you know fixing potholes
that have been put on ice because state
budgets are strapped just doing that you
can get several hundred billion dollars
of boost to the economy which given the
fact that the economy is improving would
very likely be enough to get us a long
way back towards full employment here's
another tout a short video questions
sent to us by social media hello c-span
hello mr. Krugman looking forward to
reading your book but currently reading
one of your colleagues where Thomas
freedom makes the point that the social
stability peace and one out of the world
rests largely upon the US economy so can
we pay our debt back if not what happens
then okay we don't have a problem I mean
I the United States know people who are
putting money on the line and buying
bonds don't think the United States has
a problem we had let's put this week we
have problems there are lots of things I
would worry about the United States I
worry about the increasing extremism of
one of our two great political parties I
worry about the environment worry about
all kinds of stuff but the reliability
of US debt not at all and for what it's
worth if I'm worried about the social
and political stability of the world I
think the danger spot is Europe that you
have a large part of Europe that is
really experiencing great depression
levels of unemployment and for the
moment the financial markets are calm
but what happens what happens if how
long can you sustain a stable democratic
political system when sixty percent of
young people are on are out of work
which is the situation in Spain right
now so I think it's that that's where my
concerns on that front are located wild
and wonderful on Twitter touches on what
you're talking about and says Monday's
wall street journal reported that UK's
austerity policy is producing a second
recession she wants you to comment and
also are there any models in Europe that
are succeeding so let me do that
first yeah if you look at Sweden has
handled this very well and by the way
anybody thinks that the welfare state
the excess of wealth first days the
problem should look at Sweden which has
got the biggest welfare state of the
mall and has ridden through the crisis
beautifully on my favorite the little
little economy that could Iceland which
had you know what's epicenter of the
financial crisis was the place where
they were supposed to turned into a
smoking hole in the earth but they broke
the rules they did not bail out the
bankers they did they were willing to
let the currency devalue their were
willing temporarily to have some capital
controls and Iceland has come back and
it's a decent place it's got a lower
unemployment rate than we do right now
the Britain is interesting because when
the Cameron government came in in 2010
there were a wild huzzah zuv approval
from here ready and david broder I
remembered the Washington Post said what
we need is for Obama to do a camera on
and he praised Cameron for for brushing
aside those economist who said that
austerity policies would produce another
recession guess what asperity policies
produced another recession so it's
actually in a way we should be grateful
to the tory government in Britain which
has provided us with an object
demonstration that that the Keynesian
czar right and the other guys are wrong
let's go to Lakewood New Jersey Richards
on the independent line you're talking
with Paul Krugman go ahead caller hi dr.
Kruger nice to speak with you um the
other day I was watching Morning Joe and
Richard Haass from the Council of
Economic not Economic Council of
international relations or something
with on with you and what was
frustrating for me as someone who knows
very little about economics but read
your column and is able to understand
most of it is how frustrating it must be
to have someone tell you well you've
been right all along but we can't
believe you because you might be wrong
someday yeah that's looked at if I if I
was going to give in to frustration I
would have dropped this column as gig
about 10 years ago right so uh no it is
an amazing thing and but it's kind of
what I was saying early on in this
program that it we have a set of views
that have dominated the Beltway
discourse and a lot of people are
clinging to those views despite having
been wrong at every stage despite the
views about inflation views about the
acts of deficits on interest rates which
have been wrong for four or five years
running are still treated as orthodoxy
in fact you're not considered serious
with a capital S unless you adhere to
those views despite the fact that
they've been totally wrong and but I
think we're actually i think the the ice
or the log jam is breaking a little bit
i can actually see that there's a a
slight movement at least in our policy
discourse towards what I regard as a
same position on facebook reno writes in
and asks what do you think it will take
for this presidential administration and
the legislative branch to apply it
logical sound solutions to the economic
woes of this country DC is still tone
deaf and only taking advice from those
responsible for the current economic era
I'm a little bit call me soft I actually
think that the Obama administration
although i believe they really did
misjudge stuff in late two thousand nine
and a lot of 2010 maybe even that
intertwine but I think they've gotten it
I think they figured it out at least you
know the conversations I have say that
they they have come around maybe not
fully to my point of view but to I think
they get it but they are paralyzed and
it they can't pass legislation you've
got a solid wall of opposition in the
house and boy that unless there's a
total upset in the 2014 midterms that's
not going to change so the answer is
nothing much not not these we've got to
hope the natural the natural
recuperative policies the powers that
the economy will heal largely by itself
because we're not going to get a lot of
positive help from Washington the most
you can hope for is that they don't do
active damage North Dakota Joe's up next
Republican collar where are you in North
Dakota Joe hey North Dakota hard the
state is that way in the south-central
welby's work all right great you're on
with Paul Krugman yeah okay sir I grew
up about tea questions finally asked and
they really frustrate me I'm 75 years
old the wife and I were retired we were
small farmers all our life and we paid
into Social Security all our lives and
now you always bring up that Medicare
and Social Security's break in our
economic country but they're charging us
twelve thousand six hundred dollars of a
year
for our Medicare now why should that
break Medicare we could buy nearly
health insurance for that kind of money
I don't understand that why should that
break our kitty and another taste like
sandy all the buildings they
appropriated I know a few years ago
tornado went through here it can take
six farms totally or burn down the house
editing pictures whatever they own there
is nothing mentioned from government
help ever you know what they say or they
should have had insurance well don't you
think the Sandy Hook people are wherever
over there to the head insurance it is
frustrating and another thing they say
there's no jobs in this country that is
an outright lie South Dakota alone the
state is looking for 11,000 welders so I
don't these young college kids take up
chop deals like that they want to sit
where it's a nice air-conditioned I went
through hard times about the dead doing
my farming and this is really
frustrating and I'm sorry to feel that
way but I'd like your answers hey hey
two pieces there I think I can deal with
one is I think the 12 6 that's the cost
that that's the amount that Medicare
spends per recipient I think that that
must be where it's coming from it I
don't know that that's the right number
but it's a lot but what you need to bear
in mind is that Medicare is for elderly
people many of whom have very expensive
medical needs and you cannot I twelve
thousand dollars or so is about what the
cost of an insurance policy for a family
in prime working years and it costs you
cannot ensure an elderly couple for that
amount of money it's a you know we we
actually have a cyst we have a funny
system in which the private insurance
industry gets to cover people who are in
relatively good health but the expensive
cases are already being covered by by
the government and Medicare for what
it's worth wherever we get to do
head-to-head comparisons Medicare is
actually cheaper than private insurance
substantially cheaper than private
insurance so that that's not that's
that's a
understanding of the issue jobs it's an
interesting thing the job story is that
there is a region of the United States
that does have full employment it is
North Dakota South Dakota and a little
bit of the surrounding area Nebraska I
think and yeah that's that's good
prospects but you have to have a sense
of scale right the combined population
of those three states is only a little
bit larger than the population of
Brooklyn write it this is not a large
part of the economy they're not a lot of
jobs the whole rest of the country has
high unemployment is high unemployment
the south is high unemployment in the
West as high unemployment in the
Northeast they were just is no you know
with the exception of basically the
shale driven boom states there just are
not a lot of job opportunities out there
and we can't all move to the can't i'll
move to to the Upper Great Plains to
find employment since our color from
North Dakota brought up entitlements is
there a danger of running out of money
to fund in towing program Social
Security Medicare yeah and wind is that
when does the crunch time begin free
well it's all we know there is a we have
an aging population first of all and
that's means that the cost of those
programs is going to is going to rise
and we also at least in the past we've
seen the healthcare costs rise pretty
fast and that if nothing is done about
that that causes the problem so
something if we look at the budget
outlook for the year 2030 and you just
do a straight line projection of the
cost of those programs is that a
straight line projection of revenues
will something will have to give we
can't do that so something will have to
give some combination of revenue
increases and money saving measures
whether that's ways to squeeze down the
cost of health care possibly cuts and
benefits we can art we can discuss that
that will have to happen eventually the
question that is rarely asked is why do
we have to make that decision about how
we're going to do that right now if your
fear is that in the year 2030 we will
have to know at some future date we will
have to cut benefits why is committing
right now to cuts and future benefits a
solution to that problem it's just it's
just pre determining how we're going to
do it and why why does that decision
have to
has nothing to do with fiscal
responsibility it's just about you know
maybe maybe there's some administrator
but this isn't this is a very strange
people people take a I think that this
really is a three-card Monte where
people have taken the reality of a
possible problem a couple of decades
from now and turn that into a case for
urgent action now which it isn't when is
it too late to bolster those programs
well it's when I no one is talking about
bolstering the program's that's what's
amazing the talking then changing them
so you can always cut benefits it's
never too late right can always do that
later on that the idea that somehow if
you don't cut Social Security benefits
now that you can never cut them in the
future why I've seen no rational
argument to that effect and here's a CBO
projection of the long-term budget
outlook produced last year federal debt
held by the public you can see back to
nineteen twelve and the current
situation 2012-2013 and then projected
out 20 years in the future yeah and it's
not going to happen right we we'd like
to talk about steins law that's herbert
stein Republican economist who said if
something cannot go on forever it will
stop and so in fact we will not those
those numbers will not happen the
question you want to ask is why is it
that a budget deal reached in the year
2013 has to specify exactly how it's
going to stop in the year 2030 Sarasota
Florida john is a Democrat hi John the
YES good morning can you all hear me
weekend you yes mr. Krugman first of all
I'd like to make a comment and then I
would like to make the question and
since I haven't called in many many
months please just allow me to make a
brief comment and then ask my question
my comment is this mr. Krugman I want to
thank you for what you do I'm a man on a
very limited budget taking care of my
mother down here who has been diagnosed
with dementia but I tried to every
Monday and Friday when your column
appears in the new york times i try to
get to my newsstand to see if i'm going
to buy the new york times that's how
important i think your column over the
last three to five years has been in in
league trying to assess what's going on
in our country in the world and I
appreciate many times that you're
confronted with ad hominem attacks when
I see on TV and very few people seem to
refute your ideas now here's
my question so could you please comment
on the role of corporate money in the in
the massive amounts of lobbying money in
Washington and connect that with the
demise of and the squeeze the very
tangible squeeze on middle-class
families over the last 30 years yeah
yeah okay so corporate money and money
of wealthy individuals with we don't
want to just think of it as being
faceless corporations there's a lot of
of the role of just individual
billionaires and it does distort our
political process it means that there's
a lot of lobbying and also I I
personally am always impressed by the
influence of the revolving door the
extent to which legislators public
officials are always they can't help it
they are always thinking about okay what
do i do when i leave office of course
there are are really big the really big
money comes from from interest groups
and those interest groups are more
likely to give you one of those cushy
jobs if you've been nice to them while
you were in office so it does distort
the system now this last election was
interesting because the corporate money
was pretty heavily betting on one guy
and it was the other guy who won which
shows that it's not omnipotent and i
think that is important you know i'd
like to see a lot of changes in campaign
finance I'd like to see much stricter
rules on on on on going through that
revolving door but even so the situation
is not hopeless we are still a democracy
flawed democracy but you know you can
have you can have all the big money
going behind a big-money guy for
president and have the other guy win and
that's telling you that there still hope
for America bill and Twitter wants to
know if you've ever owned a business or
operated a midsize business he said I
hear your resume in academia but how
about what bill calls true life well no
of course not but you know I maybe this
will be unpopular thing to say but
history shows that that being a good
businessman is not necessarily a
qualification for running the economy
those are those are very different
things I mean they probably had the best
businessman we've ever had as president
was a fellow named Herbert Hoover he
didn't do a very good job of managing
the economy I it's just not it's just
not
that the problems are different and it
comes back we're early on this
conversation we talked about you know
business spending versus government
spending a business when when General
Electric is deciding about what will
happen if it lays off a bunch of workers
it doesn't have to worry very much that
laying off workers will cut its own
sales but the government has to worry
about that all the time let's go to
Richard in Cincinnati on our independent
line hi Richard yeah a mr. Krugman I got
a question for you here time to time
about trillions of dollars yep sitting
in off offshore accounts by US
corporations if you had your way how
would you try and get this money back
into the United States and reinvested it
reinvest it in our economy okay I would
have said I don't know if the
corporation's I don't know how much
they're holding an offshore accounts
they're holding a lot of money just
sitting there corporations are sitting
on I believe a couple of trillion
dollars of of cash that they're not
investing but you know it's not for the
most part because they're evil I'm not I
you know some of them are but that's not
the point they they're they're sitting
on because it's a weak economy and if
you're if you've got excess capacity
your factories are not running full out
if the office buildings are not fully
occupied why build additional ones and
so the what you want in order to get
that money back to work is again give
the economy to kind of jump start it
needs to get to give corporations a
reason to invest in America Paul Krugman
author of the book end this depression
now it's just out in paperback he's a
columnist for The New York Times and
teaches at Princeton thank you so much
for joining us this way thank you
appreciate your time